Before we move on, let's get
another perspective on AI problems
by looking at how Sebastian Thrun
describes them in his artificial
intelligence class at Udacity.
>> I'm going to briefly talk of
AI as something else which is
AI as the technique of uncertainty
management in computer software.
Put it differently, AI is the discipline
that you apply when you want to
know what to do,
when you don't know what to do.
Now, there's many reasons why
there might be uncertainty
in a computer program.
There could be a sensor limit.
That is, your sensors are unable to
tell me what exactly is the case.
I would site the AI system.
There could be adversaries,
who act in a way that makes it hard for
you to understand what is the case.
It could be stochastic environments
every time you roll the dice
in a dice game, the stochasticity of
the dice who will make it important and
impossible for you to be absolute
certain of what the situation.
There could be laziness.
So perhaps you can actually
compute what the situation is.
But your computer program
is just too lazy to do it.
And here's my favorite.
Ignorance.
Plain ignorance.
Many people are just
ignorant of what's going on.
They could know it, but
they just don't care.
All of these things are cause for
uncertainty.
AI is the discipline that
deals with uncertainty and
manages it in decision making.
>> What's interesting here, is that
Sebastian's description suggest that AI
is specifically about
dealing with uncertainty, and
to a large extent that's exactly what
artificial intelligence and machine
learning are about, designing programs
that can deal with uncertain input.
Now let's go back to our course and talk
about what AI problems actually are.